- I SEE YOU WENT ALL OUT.
WAS THE HOME DEPOT
OUT OF MEXICANS?
- NO, THEY WON'T
GET IN MY CAR ANYMORE,
SINCE THE PINATA INCIDENT.
GATHER AROUND, BOYS.
IT'S PAYDAY.
- YOU'RE PAYING THEM
WITH METH?
- WHY NOT?
IT SAVES THEM A STEP.
PLUS, IT MAKES 'EM
WORK FASTER.
- THANKS, BOSS.
- WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
THIS BAG
LOOKS A LITTLE LIGHT.
- YEAH, F.I.C.A. WITHHOLDING.
- [bleep] OBAMA.
- KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK,
AND YOU BOYS
JUST MIGHT GET A RAISE.
- THANK YOU, OBAMA.
LET'S GET BACK TO WORK.
- WHAT THE--
- [muttering]
WOW, I CAN USE THAT.
YEAH, THIS'LL FIT.
THIS OUGHT TO FIT.
- AND WHO ARE YOU?
- HOBO LARRY'S NAME
IS HOBO LARRY.
YES, SIR.
- HMM.
STRAY HOBO, HUH?
- [whistling]
[squish]
HEY!
WHO THE HELL TOOK A SHIT
IN MY BOOT?
- OH, THAT MUST'VE BEEN
MY NEW PET.
- HOBO LARRY'S SORRY ABOUT THAT,
YES, SIR.
W-WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
- YOU HAVE A PET HOBO?
- YOU WOULDN'T BUY ME
MY OWN PET,
SO I HAD TO MAKE DO.
- [chuckles]
OKAY.
I SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
YOU'RE DOING THIS
TO SCREW WITH ME.
WELL, FINE. YOU WANT
A PET HOBO, HAVE AT IT.
BUT IF YOU
LET THIS ONE DIE,
IT'S THE LAST PET
YOU WILL EVER GET.
YOU UNDERSTAND ME?
EVER!
- THANKS, DADDY.
- NOW WHERE'S MY OTHER BOOT?
OH, GOD DAMN IT!
- HOBO LARRY WAS WRONG
ABOUT THAT WHOLE